[Music]
I continue my work here what I created
the most incredible technology that
allowed me to enter the interdimensional
realm which lay beyond the normal
space-time continuum I called it the
Phantom Zone hey everybody welcome to
the Phantom Zone this is gonna be my
Krypton Episode two video so they
dropped a whole bunch of Easter eggs
like the green death for instance that's
kryptonite basically so I'll explain if
you haven't read it I'll recommend which
comic books to read for this series
though I expect them to go beyond that
when we get to season 2 though but
there's like one very specific run that
they're pulling from but for all the
Krypton videos that I do I will do a
legion of super-heroes ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a Superman related
comment on the video so the big thing
here is that they revealed the Phantom
Zone he activated the fortress of
solitude so we activated his
grandfather's avatar which explains how
they can keep sir Barristan Selmy on the
TV show but obviously Phantom Zone
really big deal a lot of people asking
about whether or not jor-el created it
in the comics there's a lot of stuff
they're doing with this TV show shifting
it backwards by one or two generations
so during that comic book series it's
usually Superman going back in time to
Krypton to learn about his family there
was a run back during the 60s there was
one a couple years after that there was
one that was a little more recent but
they're all like really old super deep
cuts like most of these are pre-crisis
so a lot of it's been retcons so it is
really useful as a resource but you know
next big reveal is that Brainiac has
already come to Krypton and this sort of
backdoor confirms my voice of wrath
eerie because listen to the voice of rau
and then listen to brainiacs voice from
the trailer may rouse light for half a
guide
way of Krypton your world do you not
think that that just sounds like a
slightly different version of the same
voice like Brainiac is time-traveling
from the future to come back and change
Krypton wouldn't it make sense that the
voice of rau be some sort of Brainiac
plant or another version of Brainiac
because there's still one in there
present-day like two hundred years in
the past that's roaming around the
universe sucking up planets the way they
introduced the Brainiac mythology is his
grandfather discovers the Phantom Zone
in the way they describe it is sort of
like a subspace layer of reality
[Music]
so he uses that to quickly travel around
the universe just being a normal
Explorer while he's doing that he sees
the wake of brainiacs destruction and
they put a name on it so he learns that
this threat is eventually coming to
Krypton that's why he freaks out tells
everyone else and then the council votes
to execute him for heresy but I think
part of the idea is theorycrafting here
so this is speculation is that Brainiac
had already come to Krypton by the time
he had alerted everyone so he'd already
sort of created this theocratic state
whereby it was heresy that they suggest
the Kryptonians weren't the center of
the universe but if this is a version of
Brainiac no idea if it's the future
version of Brainiac who's hiding out
underneath this mask or if it's an older
version of Brainiac so just remember
that there are a number of different
iterations of the character he evolves
over time so we'll see what kind of
comic book twist that they put on this
we got a little more Adam Strange he
explained a little bit more about his
Zeta beams which is right out of the
comics still a little ways away from the
jetpack but they made him lose the ball
cap they put him in Kryptonian garb so I
feel like we're probably a season or two
away from him wearing a more comic book
Adam Strange costume but we haven't
quite got to the point where we've
traveled to other worlds like ran or
thanagar
so one thing at a time I think they'll
introduce those ideas and those
characters then you'll start seeing him
running around in the jetpack but if
you're not familiar with the green death
that his grandfather name dropped he
says that it happened in their planets
history so it's long gone but what
happened is is during the world of
Krypton comic book series that I was
talking about that a lot of this comes
from Superman was reading his father's
journals he learned about a green plague
that had menaced the population they
found the cause was their planet's core
had turned radioactive and that
eventually led to the planets
destruction just one of the reasons why
the planet exploded but that's basically
kryptonite their planets core was
turning radioactive the gas was what you
would think of as the green plague that
was killing the citizens so if anybody
was wondering kryptonite officially
exists on Krypton the TV show it's just
that because they're on Krypton they
don't have super powers so if somebody
were to be poisoned by it it'd be like a
normal person being poisoned by
radiation
the reason why it's such a big deal for
Superman is because he goes from being
so powerful to so weak so fast like the
swing is much bigger than a normal
person being poisoned by radiation so
just let me know in the comments what do
you guys think about the stuff that they
introduced in this episode I felt like a
couple parts of it drug a little bit but
I do like the ideas they're introducing
we still haven't met black zero there
are a couple other running storylines as
part of the political drama they have
going on the whole Nyssa vex storyline
I'm kind of hoping that she's tied up a
little bit more in the black zero and
then obviously you have all the leaders
odd stuff where she was seizing power
there were a couple fight scenes I felt
like they were okay
Georgina Campbell is a fantastic actress
but once you watch Oberyn Martell vs.
the mountain every TV fight just feels
like no big deal like arrow typically
has some of the best fights out of all
the DC shows like down and dirty fights
but part of the idea the lead azad
storyline i think is to show you how
General Zod
could be so extreme like how his family
in their circumstances could precipitate
a personality like the one that he had
so show no mercy be as hardcore as you
can possibly be protect your people at
any cost even if it means killing the
only other member of your race that's
alive on planet Earth
on Krypton the genetic template for
every being yet to be born is encoded in
the registry of citizens your father
stole the Registry's codex and stored it
in the capsule that brought you there
for what purpose so that Krypton can
live again
on earth
so remains to be seen if she'll go
completely off the deep end because she
starts off as like this really nice
person it's part of a really hardcore
family so I think they just want to show
you her slowly getting more and more
hardcore
we'll see how nuts that winds up getting
but just let me know in the comments
what you guys think of everything so far
and if you didn't see it they actually
just dropped the trailer for The Death
of Superman animated movie so I'll link
for that at the end of this but
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my Krypton Episode one video and
easy to won three please private message
me so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post new
DC Roy and Nyssa al Ghul are back on
arrow this week if you haven't seen that
episode watch it I'll post my video for
that on Friday obviously there's a whole
bunch of other stuff dropping so just
look out for that click here to watch
that death of Superman trailer and click
here for brand new Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]